[Music]
see see you can't wear red everyone's
gonna dissect why you were doing it do
you know what people said it and I was
like oh I didn't even think about it b
is somatic with the posters gonna say
that ready lots and everything li it
just said something like oh my god I'm
wearing wish and how do you think that
those remember I had seen the poster on
a tiny screen I did not see in the
trailer it is like the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen and what was it
like watching that trailer in that room
it was crazy because also cuz
hilariously I didn't really know
Joshua's like a massive fan of Star Wars
and there was one time I spoke to him
when we were filming I was like you're
wearing an actor he fell fact is pretty
nerdy anyway so he was behind me so as
we were like and then I looked around
and I was like oh my god oh my god and I
had no idea what was in it so I still
feel a bit dazed feel like I have to go
wash it wash it again and again and
again well one thing we learned today is
that Luke and Ray's relationship may not
be what she expected what can you tell
me about how their relationship evolves
around
that's about all I can tell you just
that I think it's just a level of
expectation and it's funny because I
think raised expectation is also the
audience's expectation so it's the whole
thing of what's been going on and the
interim and all that kind of stuff as it
unfolds it's Ray's experiencing
everything too but like everyone's
experiencing everything for the first
time so the audience kind of goes on
that journey with us
[Music]